وننتقل
لنستمع الى هذا المؤتمر الصحفي للمبعوث
الاممي الى
ليبيا عبد الله بتيلي
ان اعطاء الشعب الليبي
فرصه اختيار قادته
من خلال صناديق الاقتراح
هو بلا شك
السبيل نحو السلام والاستقرار
والازدهار في هذا البلد
[موسيقى]
والانتخابات ضروريه
لاستعاده واعاده بناء المؤسسات العامه
الشرعيه
التي تمثل الشعب الليبي وتخدمه
ان الترتيبات المؤقته المتتاليه
والحكومات الانتقاليه المستمره الى ما لا
نهايه والاجسام الشرعيه التي انتهت
ولايتها
الاسلام التشريعيه التي انتهت ولايتها هي
سبب عدم الاستقرار الذي يعرض مستقبل هذا
البلد للخطر
اطاله امد هذا الوضع لن يؤدي الا الى
استمرار انهيار الانهيار الاقتصادي
والاضطرابات السياسيه والاجتماعيه وتفاقم
حاله انعدام الامن وكل ذلك
سيؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى تقويض سلامه
اراضي ليبيا ووحده شعبها
منذ وصول الى ليبيا في اكتوبر من العام
الماضي
ومن مقر اقامته في طرابلس
مشاورات مكثفه مع مجموعه واسعه من
الليبيين بما فيهم رؤساء جميع المؤسسات
ذات الصله والقاده السياسيه
والجهات الامنيه والنساء
والشباب
والاعيان
وهو المرشحين البرلمانيين والرئاسيين
انا اعضاء فريقي سافرنا الى عده مدن
وبلدات في شرق ليبيا وجنوبها
وغربها ووسطها
للاطلاع على الوضع عن كثب هو الاستماع الى
اراء الليبيين من مختلف الاطياف السياسيه
والاجتماعيه حول التحديات التي تواجه
البلاد وعامه الناس وكيف كيفيه
ايجاد مخرج لهذا الانسداد السياسي الحالي
كما زرت ايضا عواصم اقليميه
فيها مشاورات مفيده للغايه مع مسؤولين
حكوميين في القاهره وتونس العاصمه
والجزائر والرباط والدوحه وابوظبي
وفي برازبيل برازبيل التي التقيت فيها
رئيس فريق الاتحاد الافريقي رفيع المستوى
المعني بليبيا
وفي الاسابيع المقبله ساذهب الى السودان
وتشاد ونيجر
جيران ليبيا من الجنوب
وتشاورت ايضا مع الشركاء ليبيا الدوليين
الرئيسيين في كل من طرابلس وعواصمهم بما
في ذلك في انقره وروما وباريس هولندا
الابعاد الاقليميه والدوليه للازمه
الليبيه واضحه للجميع ولكل من يتدبرها
للعقد الاخير
بقيت الليبيه
ساحه
[موسيقى]
نشاطات الاقليميه والدوليه ولكل قد نقلت
الى جميع الاطراف الفاعله الخارجيه رساله
واخبرتهم
بان يتحدثوا بصوت واحد وان يعملوا وفقا
لذلك
لمساعده الامم المتحده على دعم الحوار
الليبي الليبي
لانهاء الانسداد الحالي
والاستجابه للنداء الشعب الليبي الذي عبر
عنه على نطاق واسع في جميع انحاء البلاد
في تطلعاته نحو الانتخابات
في عام 2021 تسجل الليبيون باعداد كبيره
اثنين فاصله مليون مواطن سجلوا انفسهم
اسمائهم على قائمه مفوضيه الوطنيه العليا
للانتخابات
وكانت تلك رساله واضحه كان ينبغي ان
يسمعها القاده الحاليون للبلاد على جميع
المستويات
هو خلال الاشهر التي اجريت من المشاورات
المكثفه التي اجريتها مع هؤلاء القادم
شددت على الضروره الملحه باستكمال القاعده
الدستوريه
والمتطلبات القانونيه الاخرى للانتخابات
ولثلاث مرات في اكتوبر من عام 2022 من
الرباط
في المغرب وفي ديسمبر من القاهره وفي
يناير 2023 مره اخرى من القاهره
رئيس مجلس النواب عقيله صالح ورئيس المجلس
الاعلى للدوله خالد المشري انهما وقعا
اتفاقا اعلناه فيه انهما استكملان
مناقشاتهما بشان القضيه الدستوريه
ومع ذلك
بقي الخلاف قائما حول نقاط رئيسيه
كشروط الترشح لمرشحي الرئاسه
وخلال شهر فبراير وصلت لقاءاتي معهما
لحذفهما على الانتهاء من مفاوضاتهما
للاستجابه لتطلعات الشعب الليبي
بالاضافه الى ذلك
توجهت طلبا الى جميع الاطراف الاخرى
بينهم المشير حفتر واعضاء اللجنه العسكريه
المشتركه 5+5
وقاده الاحزاب السياسيه
والمرشحون الرئاسيون
القاده المدنيون والاجتماعيون
والشخصيات المستقله
لتقديم مقترحاتهم لحل الازمه
واعرب هنا عن امتناني للعدد الكبير من
الليبيين الذين قدموا مقترحاتهم
بدافع من حسن النيه
والشهور العالي بالالتزام الوطني
الدراسه المتانيه لهذه المساهمات قد
الهمتني في مبادره لاحياء
وتوسيع الحوار بين الاطراف الليبيه
كما بادر المجلس الرئاسي
الى جمع القاده الليبيين في محاوله لحملهم
على تسويه القضايا العالقه
واستكمال ما هو مطلوب منهم لاعاده العمليه
الانتخابيه الى مسارها الصحيح
واثني هنا
على المجلس الرئاسي
لجهوده
وساواصل العمل معهم
كشريك رئيسي وانا امضي للعمل بمبادلتي
التي قدمتها في 27 فبراير الى مجلس الامن
مجلس النواب وثيقه تشريعيه باسم التعديل
الثالث عشر
صادقه عليها المجلس الاعلى للدوله بعد
بضعه ايام وفقا لرئيسه رئيس المجلس
كما قرر المجلسان
لجنه مشتركه من سته اعباء من كل من
المجرتين لمناقشه القوانين الانتخابيه
عقابعه التي اعتمد بها مجلس النواب
والمجلس الاعلى للدوله التعديل الثالث عشر
واثني عليهما لاتخاذ هذه الخطوه في
الاتجاه الصحيح
ان تاتي متاخرا افضل من ان لا تاتي ابدا
واذا عملت لجنه 6 + 6 بنفس السرعه
وعالجت جميع الثغرات واوجه القصور
ضمن اطار زمنيا معقول
فخرجت بالتالي
بقاعده دستوريه وقانونيه موثوقه وقابله
للتمثيل للانتخابات فان هذا سيمثل تقدما
حقيقيا ويعيد الثقه في مجلس النواب
والمجلس الاعلى للدوله النيب البحيري
ويمكن المفوضيه الوطنيه العليا للانتخابات
من المضي قدما في الاستعدادات الفنيه
الضروريه والوفاء بالموعد النهائي لاجراء
الانتخابات هذا العام 2023
انا فريق بعثه الامم المتحده وانا نقف على
اهبه الاستعداد لدعم لجنه 6 + 6 باي شكل
من الناحيه الفنيه من ناحيه الموارد
البشريه واللوجستيه من اجل انجاز مهامها
اذا نكتفي بهذا القدر من مؤتمر الصحفي
للمبعوثه الاموي ليبيا الذي تحدث على
خلفيه المبادره الاماميه لاجراء انتخابات
هذا العام في ليبيا